herr laschet ihre größte konkurrentin im
rennen um das kanzleramt annalena
baerbock von den grünen
die wurde 2018 in einem interview
gefragt wie sie zu deutschen hilfen für
israel steht und hat dort eine wie ich
finde erschrecken der antwort gegeben
exporte an staaten die völkerrecht
brechen die saudis die stolz sagen wir
nein zu sagen wir auch in krisen
geburten soll man keine u boote liefern
die dann umgerüstet werden kann
also sie sagt hier das ist eben keine
weiteren u boot lieferungen an israel
geben soll
wie stehen sie dazu was sagen sie dazu
ich teile das nicht wir haben zur
staatsraison deutschlands gehört dann
auch israel natürlich bei seiner
verteidigung zu helfen
insofern gibt es viele kooperationen mit
israel und deshalb teile ich nicht diese
auffassung
es gibt das grundsätzliche gebot das
waffe nicht in krisenregionen geliefert
werden aber es gibt immer wieder die
einzelentscheidung wenn menschen
wirklich in ihrer existenz bedroht sind
und israel ist in einem dauernden kampf
um seine eigene existenz und deshalb
würde sich an der deutschen politik
unter meiner führung nichts ändern
wie erklären sie sich da die aussage von
frau berbalk ist das eine naive aussage
oder väter die kenntnis wie erklären sie
sich das das weiß ich nicht die auflage
liegt ja nun auch schon ein wenig zurück
vielleicht wird dass sie das heute
anders formulieren
aber wir werden noch manche außen
politische debatte in diesem wahlkampf
haben
ich teile manches nicht was frau
baerbock sagt denn es gibt eine
grundüberzeugung deutsche außenpolitik
dass wir natürlich zum frieden in der
welt beitragen wollen
aber es gibt auch einsätze wo wir sagen
die bundeswehr muss zb in afghanistan
ist in mali um für frieden und
sicherheit einzutreten und außenpolitik
bedeutet auch nicht im falle israels
aber in vielen anderen feldern in der
welt auch mit systemen zu sprechen und
sie zur umkehr zu bewegen was aber
diplomatische kontakte erforderlich
macht
und manchmal habe ich bei den grünen den
eindruck dass außenpolitik aus
überschriften besteht und der satz den
sie eben zitiert haben ist eine solche
als gesagt man muss sich ganz klar
positionieren in diesen tagen in diesem
nahostkonflikt den wir gerade sehen bei
diesen terroranschlägen gegen israel
greta tun werk ist eines der
bekanntesten mädchen der welt millionen
jugendliche und kinder schauen sie hier
und genau diese klimaaktivisten diese
ikone ihrer generation hat auf twitter
jetzt unter anderem post geteilt die
extreme hetze gegen israel waren dort
wird israel ein kriegsverbrechen nach
dem anderen vorgeworfen für wie
gefährlich halten sie das wenn
ausgerechnet jemand wie greta thunberg
genau solche dinge teilt mit ihren
millionen fans den menschen die zu ihr
hoch schauen also ich stelle bei manchen
fest die sich ja nicht mehr ganz anderen
themen engagieren und ich hatte bisher
mit den eindruck dass geräte tun
wirklich für das klima einsetzt wenn die
dann außenpolitische stellungnahmen
abgeben dass das meistens nicht sehr
durchdacht ist irgendeine sympathie für
bds zu äußern
also eine bewegung die israel und
produkte aus israel boykottieren will
künstler aus israel nicht auftreten
lassen will dazu hat der bundestag ein
deutlich stellung bezogen weit über die
parteigrenzen hinweg ist die bds
bewegung als antisemitisch beurteilt
wurden
und insofern würde ich auch
aktivistinnen künstler und viele andere
versuchen dass sie an diesem
grundkonsens den wir jedenfalls in
deutschen in europa haben nicht rütteln
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren